la visite est Express mais très
importante le Premier ministre ukrainien
Denis semihal et la première dame du
pays yolenazelenska sont à Paris ce
mardi pour une conférence de soutien à
l'Ukraine 47 pays devraient participer
selon l'Élysée au programme l'aide
internationale d'urgence
la Russie ne cesse de cibler les
infrastructures du pays par tout en
Ukraine les accès à l'eau à
l'électricité au chauffage à la
nourriture ou encore aux soins ne sont
pas garantis alors les dirigeants vont
tenter de s'accorder sur le soutien à
apporter à l'Ukraine pour permettre à la
population de passer l'hiver
la reconstruction du pays sera aussi au
cœur des discussions pour l'heure son
montant est estimé entre 400 et 700
milliards d'euros alors que la guerre
continue une réunion bilatérale entre
les autorités ukrainiennes et près de
500 entreprises françaises est également
prévues ce lundi lors d'une réunion du
G7 le président ukrainien a d'ailleurs
lancé un appel
nous devons être plus actifs dans la
reconstruction
cela montrera clairement au monde entier
les véritables capacités du système
démocratique
raccordées s'ajouteraient aux sommes
déjà alloués à Kiev sur le plan
militaire le Royaume-Uni a fourni
l'équivalent de 2,7 milliards d'euros à
l'Ukraine l'Union européenne 19,7
milliards d'euros les États-Unis plus
grand donateurs au monde l'équivalent de
68 milliards de dollars Joe Biden
réfléchit déjà à une avance
supplémentaire qu'ici elle était adoptée
porterait le montant total de l'aide
américaine à plus de 100 milliards de
dollars